now walk into this video I'm playing NM
moles mmm probably new master of puppets
2 3 44 from the US king's indian i'm
going to play let's see yeah i'm always
amazed the classical is so popular and
still most why players get it mate it so
often in the classical okay anyway let's
um play this super aggressive line where
black allows to get his Queen side
destroy to the system I'm an interesting
way to play
94 Knight f6 f3 this kind of line
he's so taking some time yeah this is
certainly also possible at him it's not
later so often so similar to them to the
main line with rookie one but here's
some are working one hasn't been played
and that's the difference before night h
5 rupee one f5 hmm let's simula now
played the same moves
yeah I have no idea so what is black
supposed to do here is going from 96 of
course I can FYI probably probably
nonsense I can take yeah okay I need to
play it with one moment I don't really
know this line at all this isn't this
isn't the most aggressive way to play
but it shouldn't be too terrible i
always have 98 52 d for something like
that i have some active pieces
yeah maybe i can i can even go to be six
active square do need to play Queen the
eighth or something so let's let's kick
this away we have an annoying piece
they're always there should be seven and
so on in the mix now I need to activate
the snot now here maybe I should have
taken maybe
okay so a simple way would be to just
take it but it's a simple that also not
particularly great
hmm now I don't really have a complete
plan here what is my plan to improve the
position d 5 is sun protected him but i
don't really see how I could take it
hmm
yeah and of course its own the bishop on
geez have met some not particularly
great yeah okay
and queen age four but um teste 6mm not
good
ok ah
I want a goober should be 50 k him he
wants to trade so I have a nice square
on c3 now yeah don't think this is so
bad for me the light squares a week of
course but its its opponent I mean this
isn't a completely clear cut position 94
m
ok yeah i saw that these six hangs but i
think i thought i could ok I didn't this
I didn't really I can didn't really see
ok but I don't think it's a big deal
I've got all those active back alive
I've got active pieces on c3 and so on
unless there's some some tactical thing
yeah maybe night night Fox 97's new
night 94 stupid
night see 523 this is this is a gleam a
night b7 as well yeah this is a real
unnecessary loss it was completely
unnecessary to do that I'm pretty sure
at one point I had a bad a fine position
but Brooke on c3 and scientists can
never be too bad but I screwed it up I
just screwed it up
yeah this is probably not not working at
all but what can you do my completely
seven this seven king is a blue p1 check
quite simple
37 what's so difficult about that okay
now I'm very much alive
check-check time warning check check
check check
check check check white forfeits on time
yeah complete completely gifted me this
game d7 was just a very simple win I'm
done nice I don't really get it I mean
it's very easy just d7 check and I
learned it's gone king d 8 9 p-7 check
I'm turkey nice ebony Scott rookie one
check Saudis haven't just wins but I
didn't have a move so but um the thing
that interests me most is where when how
or did I did I screw this up exactly
here I felt that I should have a good
position simply because of this this
this Roxy three this is very active ok
so i pled king a queen f6 takes computer
recommends this this is interesting and
says white black has got a good
compensation hmm yeah now that I think
of it
yeah this is interesting it's I'm not
sure about enough compensation but there
is some compensation i can get pawns i
have c troop c4b should be two ideas
yeah this is interesting I felt that
there should be something I didn't see
that one and probably in the Blitz game
I'm not sure I could come up with that
that kind of concept but it's
interesting yeah I'm he's chatting a bit
with me alright thanks for watching this
game